bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france pour commenter un petit
peu ce qui se passe aujourd'hui au liban
alors la première question puisque vous
êtes sur place d'après l'orient-le jour
les partisans aller tirso fou entre les
partisans du hezbollah et d'amal et les
forces libanaises partie de samir geagea
est ce que vous confirmer cette
information
en effet mon fils pour des formations
sécuritaire en tant que juriste tu peux
vous dire que la situation au liban a
commencé par une confrontation
judiciaire
abobo du juge elle vitol et actuellement
s avère une question politiser une
question qui est qui vole une
confrontation sécurité au sein de la
capitale libanaise et sinon ça va être
vraiment une une explosion ou sécurité
dans tout le pays si le gouvernement ne
plongera pas des allongements rapide
imminent ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
est terrible et délicatement comment est
ce que vous expliquez cette nouvelle
flambée de violence
effectivement c'est une c'est une
question puis tombe politique qui a
commencé par la question judiciaire et a
appelé à certains moments vu que le
gouvernement vienne n'a pas pu prendre
une décision envers le juge et le juge
d'habitants il ya une question simple
précise et concise de la part de
do you she afin de limoger le juge du
pit a probablement juge pose problème
pourquoi est-ce qu'il ya autant de
pression et d'intimider d'intimidation
de la part du hezbollah et amal
en effet la question où julie ciel se
lient et se situe au niveau de la
compétence si le juge était compétent ou
c'est le parlement heures ou plutôt le
haut conseil pour le jugement des
présidents et les ministres il ya une
question de litigieux litigieuse de
compétences entre le juge et la classe
politique qui gouverne le pays c'est sam
et callen problème sur le plan juridique
jeudi et judiciaires en guinée mais
actuellement c'est plus une question
politique le conseil des ministres au
liban n'a pas le droit de l'utiliser ou
de limoger le juge a levé tôt vu qui a
un principe constitutionnel qui
concrétise le la séparation entre les
pouvoirs entre le pouvoir législatif
exécutif et judiciaire
c'est pour cela c'est pas un jeu c'est
pas une question de j'espère y danse ni
m une question qui devait discussions
politiques c'est pour cela juge
actuellement continue son travail vu que
la cour de cassation appelée une
décision aujourd'hui qui a si vous
voulez qui a calé son la confiance si je
peux dire ça au niveau que le nouvel le
juge vital peut continuer et doit
continuer ses enquêtes l enquête n est
justement suspendus pour l'instant on
l'a vu la justice allait très lente ça
fait plus d'un an que l'explosion du
porc halal yeux toujours rien on sent le
corps judiciaire paralysé les mains
liées il vient toujours un motif qui
suspend l enquête pourquoi cette lenteur
aujourd'hui vu que tout est politisé au
liban mais actuellement appelé la
décision de la cour de cassation de
rejeter si vous voulez le
dessaisissement du juge
le juge va continuer son travail oui en
effet les quatorze mois suite à ce crime
contre l'humanité qui est un des loops
le 4 août et 2020 vue à cet effet mans
c'était catastrophique
il ya des gens qui aiment subissent
toujours à l'oeuvre sur le plan
judiciaire oui il ya une certaine
lenteur j que la politique est là vu que
tout est politisé le liban il ya aucun
dossier qui a été ouvert et a on a vu sa
fin il n'y a pas de coupe a pas de
responsable le pays a été mise en
faillite a été volé et jusqu'ici il n'y
a pas de coupable par des responsables
et on attend toujours des choses d'ici
et de là toujours il ya des ce qu'on
appelle ans en politique tu es margaine
kong ont fait des concessions alors mais
le pays ne peut pas continuer comme ça
c'est une mine vous parler de
responsabilités
antoine sfeir vous parler de
responsabilités dans quelle mesure la
classe politique est responsable de
l'explosion apparemment causées par les
stock de nitrate d'ammonium elle
déposait son sens mesure de précaution
qu'elle est le le rôle du hezbollah et
d'autres aussi peut-être je les bats
c'est marrant je n'ai pas vu le
lan ken hill et les détails
je suis votre question je suis je suis
beau jeu si vous voulez c'est le juge
qui doit prendre la décision dans ce
sens évaluer et suivant le pouvoir
discrétionnaire donner aux juges puis
d'emblée au alors la couleur la cour de
judiciaire le les responsabilités
pourtant bien précisé
est ce qu'on peut penser que la
responsabilité de plusieurs politiques
est impliqué et c'est ce qui provoque la
lenteur de ce dossier je veux dire une
chose une telle constatation
que seulement il ya des responsables il
ya des responsables bien par
mon diligence ou bien des responsables
qui ont parlé pas le nonchalant c'est
vous voyez air à cause de tout ça le
pays a été mise en faillite et le crime
du pôle a eu lieu et d'autres les crimes
de même et il ya toujours des discours
sans faille des discours sans fo qui ne
donne plus rien aux libanais et
actuellement nous sommes vraiment en
état de désarroi sur tous les plans
alors que peut faire le gouvernement de
najib mikati pour apaiser justement les
tensions il a appelé au calme est ce
qu'on peut s'attendre à une nouvelle
flambée de violence à beyrouth
j'espère que les choses de selon un peu
calmée dans les heures qui viennent j'ai
eu des
informations de quelques politiciens
journalistes qui avait vraiment des
concertations que les politiciens qui a
classe politique qui gouverne le pays
enfin de calmer les chiffres qu'on doit
attendre mais le gouvernement doit
prendre des arrangements sécuritaires et
données pour l'armée libanaise le
pouvoir de vraiment prendre des
décisions qu elle afin que la violence
ne pourra plus lieu ni dans les heures
qui viennent ni dans les prochains jours
de méditation
vraiment au niveau au niveau
communautaire haut niveau si vous voulez
politique on peut pas continuer comme ça
c'est un pays qui aient besoin d'une
aide du fonds monétaire international de
la communauté internationale on peut pas
continuer par des 6 brûlés qui n'est pas
le déniaiser il ya des gens il est vital
il ya six morts il ya des blessés il y
avait des étudiants des élèves les
enfants courent dans les écoles dimitrov
qui fut vraiment terrifié cette ellipse
qui sait pas c'est qu'au début ça nous a
rappelé les des jours noirs de la guerre
tu dis merci antoine sfeir pour votre
analyse est votre témoignage ravale que
vous êtes avocat elle y balle est maître
de conférences à l'université
saint-joseph merci d'avoir été elle